[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
on the series called High School
memories my name is flina PLA and I'll
be your host today so without further
Ado let's dive into today's episode and
embark on a great journey together get
ready to be engaged entertained and
inspired today's topic will be about
mental health awareness mental health
refers to an individual's emotional
psychological and social well-being it
encompasses various aspects of a
person's mental and emotional state as
well as their ability to manage and
adapt to Life's challenges and stressors
this means experiencing a range of
emotions in a balanced way including
Happiness joy sadness anger and fear it
also includes the ability to manage and
express these emotions in a healthy
manner it pertains to cognitive
processes such as thinking learning
memory and problem solving good mental
health implies clear thinking the
ability to learn from experiences and
effective problem solving skills mental
health encompasses the quality of one's
interpersonal relationships and social
interactions healthy mental health
includes the ability to form and
maintain satisfying relationships
communicate effectively and social
support when needed a critical aspect of
mental health is resilence which is the
capacity to cope with life's challenges
adversities and setbacks resilent
individuals can adapt and recover from
difficult situations and maintain a
positive outlook it includes the ability
to manage stress in a healthy manner
people with good mental health can
effectively cope with stressors engage
in relaxation techniques and and
practice selfcare to reduce stress
mental health is related to self-image
and self-esteem a positive self image
and self-esteem contribute to
self-confidence and a strong sense of
selfworth healthy mental health often
includes a sense of purpose and meaning
in life this entails setting and
pursuing personal goals having a
direction in life and feeling motivated
it involves the capacity to manage one's
emotions and actions in a balanced and
adaptive way this includes the ability
to control impulses and make rational
decisions even in emotionally charged
situations mental health also
encompasses one's ability to respect the
feelings boundaries and perspectives of
others people may face various
challenges and stressors that impact
their mental health and these
fluctuations are normal mental health
issues may arise when individuals
experience difficulties managing their
emotional psychological or social
well-being these issues can rage from
mild and short-term challenges to more
severe and persistent conditions such as
anxiety disorders depression bipolar
disorder and
schizophrenia prioritizing and
maintaining good mental health is
essential for overall well-being and a
balanced fulfilling life seeking support
from mental health professionals as well
as from friends and family can be a
valuable resource for addressing and
managing mental health challenges mental
health awareness is like a warm embrace
in a world that sometimes feels cold and
distant is the gentle whisper that says
you are not alone is the hand that
reaches out to pull you back when you
are on the edge of Despair imagine it as
a light in the darkness guiding those
who are lost in the Labyrinth of their
own minds it's a Lifeline thrown to
someone drowning in a sea of
self-doubt mental health awareness is
the kind voice that reminds us that it's
okay to not be okay it's a space where
you can share your deepest fears your
heaviest burdens and your darkest
thoughts without judgment or
condemnation is the silent tears shed by
those who understand the silent
struggles of others it's a bridge that
connects hearts and souls where
compassion and empathy replace the cold
harsh judgment mental health awareness
is the lifeline that holds the promise
of hope and healing is the collective
sigh of relief when someone takes that
first Brave step towards seeking help
mental health is the very essence of our
inner world is the compass guiding our
emotions thoughts and feelings through
life's vast and often
turbulencias its importance is
immeasurable like the air breathe the
heartbeats that Echo our existence and
the colors that paint our emotional
landscape it's crucial to acknowledge
that mental health is as important as
physical health and prioritizing it is
essential for personal well-being and
societal Health Silence has long been
the shadow shrouding mental health The
hushed Whispers And sideways glances
have perpetuated the stigma leaving many
to suffer in silence mental health
awareness breaks the silence it
encourages open conversations
vulnerability and the sharing of
personal experiences stigma is the Venom
that poison our perceptions of mental
health it labels those who suffer as
weak or broken casting judgment upon
those who already bear heavy burdens
mental health awareness campaigns
tirelessly work to eradicate the stigma
they challenge the misconceptions the
myths and the Discrimination that
surround mental health issues striving
to replace ignorance with understanding
empowerment through education is at the
heart of mental health awareness when we
understand the sence signs and symptoms
of mental health disorders we are better
equipped to recognize them both in
ourselves and in others education
empowers individuals to seek help and
support and to navigate the complex
terrain of their emotions mental health
awareness isn't solely about mental
illness it's about promoting well-being
it emphasizes self-care Stress
Management and resilence building
helping individuals stay on the path of
emotional and mental Wellness advocates
for mental health tirelessly push for
change they Lobby for policy adjustments
better funding for mental health
programs and legal protections for
individuals facing mental health
challenges their advocacy aims to
improve access to mental health care and
ensure that those in need can receive
the support they deserve building
supportive communities is vital these
networks offer safe spaces for
individuals to share their
experiences seek help and exess
resources they are the beacons of Hope
in the darkest of nights proving that
compassion and empathy are cornerstones
of our Humanity the workplace is a
pivotal arena for mental health
awareness recognizing the impact of
mental health and productivity and the
overall work environment employers are
encouraged to create supportive
workplaces that prioritize employee
well-being the media plays a significant
role in shaping public perceptions
mental health awareness Ness campaigns
work to ensure that portrayals of mental
health in media are accurate sensitive
and devoid of harmful stereotypes Mental
Health First Aid training programs have
gained popularity these programs teach
individuals how to provide the initial
support to someone experiencing a mental
health crisis much like physical first
aid mental health awareness encourages
individuals to seek help when needed
normalizing therapy and counseling and
creating access ible avenues for support
mental health awareness is a collective
effort to shine a light on the
intricacies of our emotional worlds it
is the voice that cries you matter the
hand that reaches out to help and the
bridge that connects hearts and souls
it's a call to end the silence and
stigma surrounding mental health making
space for empathy understanding and
support mental health awareness isn't
just a campaign it's an ongoing
commitment to making mental health a
priority in our life our communities and
our societies by raising awareness
reducing stigma and fostering a culture
of empathy and support we can
collectively contribute to better mental
health for individuals today and in the
brighter more hopeful tomorrow that
alwayss thank you so much for joining us
on this episode of high school memories
it's been an incredible journey until
next time take
care